now that biden is showing his radicalism
we are seeing pushback already with one
uh congressman representative marjorie
taylor greene
filing articles of impeachment against
joe biden
already he what he's two days into his
presidency now
she's already filed articles of
impeachment i think it's absolutely
hilarious
here is her reasoning just filed
articles of impeachment on president joe
biden
we'll see how this goes now i say that's
her reasoning
because that's basically all impeachment
is going to mean from now on
i i think the legal argument has
something to do with
the massive evidence of his corruption
in china which was suppressed by the big
tech companies
before the election the hunter biden
scandal that was completely shut down
you couldn't even message the article
because they wanted to throw the
election for
for joe biden and then only after it
didn't matter anymore did they
finally reopen that there was a study
that came out from
the media research center that i think
was something like 14
of biden voters could have changed their
vote had they known about that scandal
so that's
i guess ostensibly the legal basis but
that's not really at the
the basis for impeachment is purely
political in this case which is
you're going to impeach my guy multiple
times well i'm going to impeach your guy
and that's probably the way politics is
going to start working
probably there i mean they're still
impeaching
the past the previous president so there
will there will be a senate impeachment
trial for donald trump who cannot be
impeached because he's no longer in
office
and i know that there are some people
who think this is an open constitutional
question it's constitutionally absurd
that the president can be convicted
impeached and convicted
after he has left office it cannot
happen
and if it does happen it's it's a
constitutional absurdity and outrage
so now the republicans are going to file
impeachment against biden
fined by me totally fined by me
why is it because i think impeachment
should be used this way
no i don't think impeachment should be
used this way i think it's a wrong way
to use impeachment
but impeachment is used this way and i
don't think that we're going to restore
a more dignified kind of politics by
unilaterally disarming i think that's
what we've done for a very long time and
it and it didn't work out very well
we kind of tried this already you know
barack obama committed
impeachable offenses notably in his
irs scandal uh notable fast furious
would be another example but the irs was
really bad doj he uh spied on
his political rivals and tried to
undermine their campaigns if we're
allowed to now impeach and convict
presidents after they've left office
let's do that let's impeach obama
but we tried okay i don't i don't want
to hear this is what we're going to hear
they're going to say republicans started
all of this because in the 90s they
impeached bill clinton over
some eccentric activities in the oval
office private matter
well that's not true he was impeached
for perjury but even putting that aside
okay let's say let's say the clinton
impeachment was ill-advised let's say it
was political even
okay or partisan rather rather than
having a legal basis
fine we did not impeach
barack obama when we could have john
boehner and mitch mcconnell refused to
do it
did that buy us good will did that
restore us to a dignified kind of
politics
no they impeached trump they actually
did exactly what marge retailer green
did
everyone remembers well the current
impeachment and they remember the the
impeachment a year ago people forget the
articles of impeachment filed in 2017.
representative al green interestingly it
was another representative green
who first proposed impeaching trump in
2017.
right at the beginning of his presidency
why well green's argument was
if we don't impeach trump he might get
reelected that's the argument for
impeaching him now
they're saying if we don't impeach trump
and convict him in the senate
he might run for office again and get
reelected does that sound like people
who think that they have
the majority of americans on their side
does that sound like people who think
that democracy is going to triumph
for them does that sound like people who
believe their views are really
really popular i don't think so i think
it sounds like people who
who know that the only way that they're
going to win is through
chicanery through irregularity i'll
leave it at that
[Music]
you